oh my god this is weird why do they have
zombies in a hospital what's up guys dr.
Mike here for those of you who don't
know I am a board-certified family
medicine physician but I'm also a gamer
part-time and I've been trying to break
into Minecraft for some time luckily I
found a buddy and logged dot zip aka
Tyler to help me out he guided me
through the process I downloaded some
hospital maps and I'm about to give you
a review how accurate these hospital
maps are what I would change I'm linking
them all down below so the creators can
get your downloads as well let's get
started modern hospital hospital I'm
gonna click I know what I'm doing I'm a
physician okay I see a sheep first of
all I want to come out really far away
and take a look at this hospital because
this hospital looks more like a miami
condo than it does a hospital is this
like the garden where patients go to
garden oh my god I've never played this
game I get to hit stuff oh look at these
little seagulls wait what what what is
this look like a little baby eggplants
what are these you think they're fishies
wait a second look at that little
positive sign that's nice let's take a
look at the whips that they put in front
of the hospital this is kind of a wack
car this looks like a Hummer circa 1984
wait why are there pigs in front of the
hospital so it had a way too good of a
time and then there's bones mmm you
could pick this stuff up can I get the
little piggy come here little piggy
piggy piggy piggy piggy piggy piggy
okay I'm trying to ride the piggy piggy
let me ride you no don't hit the piggy
that's a seagull - seagulls attack in
this game I will say whoever created
this their gardening is on point oh look
it's a person or is that a security
guard it's definitely a security guard
because my man's got a bow a bow put
that bow down bro
I'm sorry I'm creating havoc in the
hospital let's go what is over here this
is not a hospital what is that why is
this thingy like this high and these
spiders just look concerning to me
there's like animals in here is this a
veterinary hospital bro is this just if
someone just designed a hospital on the
exterior that looks really good I'll
give you props but I expect more I just
heard a sheep baa failure the game
number one you got to have an elevator
to hospital dad's like we're all the
HIPAA violations take place so there's
just friggin spiders everywhere how are
you ever gonna get better when there's
spiders yo this thing is writing the
spider it doesn't even care
this is one unhappy page why is it green
why are you green buddy I'm going to the
top floor we're going to the penthouse
oh my god this person made the hospital
go above the clouds oh look at these
little ventilators okay the first
accurate part of this hospital little AC
vet units what I would do I would
confuse people and just say by now you
don't know what it is it just looks like
a pause logo we have to take out all
signage to not confuse people so they
don't think this is a hospital because
there's no hospital in going on here I'm
giving this hospital on an exterior
level I give it a 7 it looks beautiful
but it doesn't look like a hospital Ike
it has balconies you don't have
balconies
a hospital you don't have pools just
hanging out here for patients to swim in
interior I give it a zero you don't even
have an elevator or stairs how you to
get the patients from one floor to
another you gotta think about this
I'm starting to get a feel for this I'm
kind of thinking like if I built my own
be a good Hospital just saying oh this
one already is like come in to me this
hospital speaks to me I probably
wouldn't put the logos like that like
here and here like that's too much like
is this for people and then this is for
the birds
and they got a helicopter pad move I was
a helicopter I'd land here the pool Shh
I don't know why I like breaking stuff
this is a good roof like this is the
proper antenna that you need for
cellular communication that kind of
looks like a laser so that's a little
strange
these need to be on the roofs of tall
buildings because we're so high in the
clouds you don't want like an airplane
being like oh what is that oh my god
honestly outside it's clean its thorough
but it doesn't have any landscaping you
know the landscaping is gonna cost you
some points I'm gonna say I'm gonna give
this hospital straight seven just a fact
that it doesn't have any kind of
landscaping except these bouncy bushes I
don't like it that's what the spiders
man this one has a spider too
I'm telling you hospitals don't have
spiders all right let's go through the
main entrance there's a seagull oh look
there's employees with bows and arrows
you come in here and you say I'm here
because I have a bone that's broken oh
you go to the waiting area and they're
like sir we'll call you when you're
ready and you're like oh whoa oh no oh
no dr. Mike fell out of the world score
for okay respond me I need to do that
again that was bad is this this is a
double room my god is this a sink this
looks like a jail oh is this a jail
hospital
[Music]
the sound effects of this game are
freaking me out
whoa whoa where was that I saw something
move is this cuz I fell out they put me
into the hospital okay I need to get out
of here I'm speaking yes I'm freaking
out
no I've managed to curtail my fall oh my
god this is weird why do they have
zombies in a hospital and there's bats
in here they need to fix this place up
and why they're stairs right here why
there oh oh wait what is that what is
that bacon rotten flesh you first of all
why they channels like this looks like
free the patient free the patients now
it looks like a hospital now let's
expand these rooms see now you have a
connecting room now people can hang out
together and it's like more sociable
okay exterior I said was a seven
interior has really disappointed me it's
not like a one I'm gonna give the
interior a three out of ten
so and this one I'm not gonna take away
their full accreditation I'm just gonna
take away their L so it's a hospitai and
it's raining I don't like that it's
raining I'm gonna leave now
oh this hospital is very very cute I
love the color scheme if I was a patient
I would be excited to go to this
hospital there's a lot of support
animals there's emotional support sheep
emotional support bushes they didn't
even try and make it big they were like
this is a tiny Community Hospital for
small doctors like dr. Mike to come in
and see what's up I love the design and
again there's spiders what's with the
zombies and the spiders it is the
reception you come in and you again you
say hey I have something wrong with me
help me help me and the person's like do
you even have insurance and I'm like no
help me I should live in a country where
we are all covered then I realized I was
getting political in a game like
Minecraft so I decided take the stairs
so I'm assuming these are exam room
come on they didn't even put patient
beds in here
what is this bench what are you supposed
to do in this bench besides look at this
beautiful view and the emotional support
animals there's one more floor I hope to
be pleasantly surprised you're not
supposed to have open flames in a
hospital bro don't you know that oxygen
tanks are flammable put all of these out
immediately and you want to have
curtains up just in case patients need a
little privacy
this is ridiculous I'm getting
frustrated and the roof just has AC
vents and nothing else
I'm disappointed this hospital gets like
a 4/5 I think it's cute on the outside
the inside is a solid one because
there's like some thought behind the
lighting setup but I'm taking away its
medical privilege that's it no that kind
of still looks like it has medical
privilege we got it yes okay now it just
looks like someone's weird home next
there's something addicting about
Minecraft where you don't have to worry
about the real world just build some
blocks I think this is the psychiatric
hospital that I saw look at the exit cuz
you can't walk out by sea I like it
because you can't really escape from
here there's like you know barbed wire
and then I'm not sure what's going on
with here this looks rather unfinished
the logo I like these little lighting
designs this looks nice this needs to be
figured out I will say the roof the roof
is good this is a good roof you have
lights here for planes you have like
this area where you can what is this
like a cooking area sound alarm if
Escape is suspected oh this is the
watchtower this roof is really looking
legit I'm liking this roof this is a
good roof I would like for it to have a
helicopter landing pad in case of a
psych emergency I can live without it
outdoors this is like a solid seven and
a half seven and three-quarters
all right let's let's go in what does it
say here ambulance docking gate three I
like these deeds
you see these details are what we could
go along way like coz if you told me
pull up to gate g4 I beg your where's
gay g4 get you boys right here
assessment unit white forest max stay 40
oh this is like the short-term stay yo
this is not bad but like you need to
have a nursing station cuz like I get
that these are little rooms for the
patient first of all don't be a savage
give your patients at least a 10 foot by
10 foot room this is not a [ __ ]
inhabitable
this one has double doors so you know
this is where the dangerous people stay
so it has a window at least whoever made
this hospital did not recognize that
humans live in psych wards or stay in
psych wards so they need room they're
not like chickens they need like a
little henhouse let me out I feel like
I'm a patient I'm not about it I would
like to see my patients taking care of
better than this
is this blood let's let's get out of
here I'm creeped out a little bit in
tear this hospital gets a solid four
because they actually labeled stuff the
signs are legit the outsides a solid
seven and a half eight but it looks more
like a prison than anything else I'm
over it I'm building my own hospital if
you get this video to a hundred thousand
likes for now I want you to watch this
memes video because I guarantee you it's
gonna make you laugh or your money back
and if this doesn't make you laugh this
onion reviewing article video thing will
make you laugh even more as always stay
happy and healthy
[Music]